game on 5's represents five minutes
standard play there's standard play and
there is Fisher random play we're gonna
have Petroff again I'd have six takes
takes sleep defense it's lame defense
maybe okay
Roy Lopez no it's baby step it baby step
it I don't want to enter Castle Knight
takes rook e1 blah blah blah I don't
want you to enter that variation let's
go with c3 preparing to retreat retreat
Bishop c2
I don't know if there's a big difference
between castle or 92 I'm gonna go at 92
yeah okay let's come all the way back I
don't want to deal yeah I definitely
want to just come all the way back well
then support to this guy also by if
there is a difference between knight
Knight B to d2 and Castle kingside
it lies in the fact that maybe I want to
first pivot on f1 go to g3 and then
castle in other words if I'm not really
seeing a use for making a rook move or
for when it's on f1 to e1 then I
probably should be going with this Queen
Knights deployment first let him go on
his little journey to g3 then I'll
castle and at the end of the day I'll
end up saving a move keep that in mind
this is a blitz game but that is an
important detail to be aware of you
could as a result be buying yourself a
move could be advancing this setup
93 let's roll and now I want a castle
soon I do want to be also cautious of
this f-pawn plush a knight now this this
square right now is keeping my opponent
out of h5 let's castle its castle and
what
um let's see
mmm
well Queen e2 is my first thought and I
think it's the right move reason for
that I want to be able to maintain a
pawn on this square and the Queen's on
the board I need to be able to I need my
Queen off the D file if that is to be
the case so if de d what's the big deal
about me maintaining upon on e the big
deal lies in the fact that if I don't
first and foremost the knight could
pivot on d5 and then look to get to
maybe f4 but the main thing really is
that after the knight moves f5 is all of
a sudden available my king gets my Queen
gets pushed around and then pawn push
again my knight gets pushed around nope
nope nope I do not want to have to deal
with that so that's why capturing on
this square with the pawn is important
so as a result of this last decision by
black to give up their light square
Bishop my eyes are immediately fixated
on the light squares on the board
f7 maybe my Bishop getting back on this
diagonal is going to be good also that
was their better Bishop when considering
the two bishops they're dark and light
square bishop this that guy was very
important I do have these two squares
available to my knight the bishop
bearing down on this square the Queen
playing here is threatening Bishop takes
h6 I do have Queen here clean here
night here is on this bishop I think I
want to chase the Queen away first get
that Queen out of there and then and
then play here hmm
I think Bishop hears on the cards let me
let me just do this right here and what
next
Oh Queen dat queen of g3
come on g7 g 7h 6 e 7 a night on this
square if your castle if both sides are
castle down the Kings side and a white
knight ends up on f5 you should be very
scared if you're on the white side and
your opponent has a black knight an F
for the same thing be very scared
there's a winning move here I just have
a feeling that's my first thought
there's just too many pieces around here
doing too many good things my Bishop
Knight and Queen there's something going
on something going on here so what is it
I also have this as a possibility rook
here but there's something something
tells me there's a sac on one of these
two Queen g3 or g4 this is at least
winning upon playing my queen to one of
these two squares Queen g3 is there any
difference between the two probably not
I may not even take this pun
if pawn push I might actually want to
just play my Bishop to b3 which would
then be threatening a million to
okay million to threat that pond is
pinned and this pot is now threatened
this pond is not going anywhere
not going anywhere he's hit twice
defended zero hit twice defended zero
it's very unlikely that there's a way to
defend it it's very unlikely that my
opponent can make one move and have all
of a sudden two pieces defending that
pond hit twice defended zero what do we
got King in the corner maybe it's being
overlooked that I could be taking on g6
I have my two bishops Knight and Queen
attacking my opponents King this night
is out of play on c6 this pond negates
it this Bishop not doing anything the
rook isn't doing anything the Knights
kind of just sitting and they're less
than 10 seconds away less than 10
seconds out so this is defense but they
had to really exhaust a lot of time
there I'm gonna just take it and then
take on this square or actually let me
do this first I'm on the rook if the
rook moves then I would take here okay
now I could actually take here first
right here let's take that and then this
and then this Bishop lock on everything
at that point okay
okay game rule out PES so there was a
lot of maneuvering early on a lot of
maneuvering good game let me back up
here copy copy that and right here okay
so I don't know about the bishop move
I don't know that this bishop knows its
place just yet a lot of times you'll
just delay that guy's development look
at look at the choices that both bishops
have which one has more choices this guy
reserved those choices
how many options does he have one might
as well do it get it over with this is
not gonna be a surprise to me I'm I
already know I already know you're gonna
do that so do the moves you know I
already know that's a weird way to view
it but what I'm getting has retained
flexibility
maybe here maybe here maybe here or
maybe b5 Bishop d7 he has a lot of
choices retain those choices so Bishop
e7 is what I'm getting at there's
probably an improvement I don't know
about well this is all this decision
right here the decision to give up the
light square bishop probably not a good
one probably not a good one and the
decision to actually release the tension
maybe that's not good either I wonder if
you can be doing something like b5 if
you can make this pot and move somehow
and then get your knight to d4 maybe
that's an idea so look into that maybe
there's something involved with b5 takes
and then push or actually how about this
consider push here capturing on c3
and then undermining my pawn push take
push take and then you have this square
available for your knight and in this
game the knight really was not able to
contribute so this this sequence of
moves is at the very least a way that
you can now know to be activating your
knight on c6 because as its as I stood
in this game my pawn alone took that
night out one point was constraining
three that by the way is what I use
quite a bit when I'm assessing positions
I'm doing a point like a little bit of a
point system I'm seeing three I'm seeing
one I'm like okay I'm kind of playing up
a piece in a sense you know I'm
constantly doing these little
comparisons and eventually it starts to
paint the whole picture a bit more
clearly as to what exactly is going on
and who would maybe be the favorable
side as a result one poorly placed piece
could translate into you just having a
poor position so keep that in mind keep
that in mind that idea d5 or excuse me
d4 takes b4 it takes and then Knight to
d4 your knight has something to do at
least the decision to get out the lights
grand Bishop I think is just turns out
to not be good these two squares are too
great too great can't they can't allow a
knight to come here and sit and that's
why I was already feeling at this point
that like I had something right here
well I didn't say it at this point but
it was close to that point when the
knight is able to get to this square
it's just a very valuable position